YOUR LIKE BRIAN KILMEADE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU BOTH.
NIGHT TWO, WORST INFOMERCIAL
EVER.
ALSO WE CALL IT THE 2020 DNC
ADAM SCHIFF SHOW.
BUT NOTHING BUT SEVERAL
DEMOCRATS TELLING BIDEN COME OF
THIS CAMPAIGN’S FAR LEFT AGENDA,
MORE LAUGHTER THAN ANY MAJOR
POLITICAL PARTY IN HISTORY, JOHN
KASICH’S MADNESS.
HERE WITH REACTION TO ALL OF
THIS, SENIOR WHITE HOUSE ADVISOR
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
I’M SURE YOU ARE ONE OR TWO
THINGS TO SAY ABOUT ALL OF THIS.
>> HEY, THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
FOUR YEARS AGO I WAS WITH YOU IN
PHILADELPHIA AND WE WOULD SAY
WOW, HAVE YOU EVER SEEN SUCH A
GRIEVANCE-FILLED CANDIDATE
NOMINEE THAT’S FECKLESS AND
RECKLESS AND CANTANKEROUS AND
THE ANSWER IS YES, EVEN MORE SO
NOW.
YOU GOT JOE BIDEN WHO BEAT ALL
THE SOCIALIST RADICAL IDEAS IN
THE PRIMARY AND THE CANDIDATES
WHO CARRY THEM NOW CAPITULATING
ON CONGRATULATING THE SAME
PEOPLE.
YOU’VE GOT LOTS OF FOLKS WHO’VE
BEEN IN AND OUT OF WASHINGTON
FOR DECADES.
BILL CLINTON, THEY GAVE HIM LESS
THAN 5 MINUTES TONIGHT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE AVERAGE TIME
HE SPOKE IN THE LAST SEVEN OR
EIGHT DEMOCRATICS DEMOCRATIC CON
HIS ROLE HAS SHRUNK BECAUSE THE
PARTY THAT HE TRIED TO BE A
MODERATE AND NO LONGER EXISTS.
IT HAS BEEN TAKEN OVER BY THE
SQUAD THAT DOESN’T DO SQUAT,
IT’S BEEN TAKEN OVER BY THE
BERNIE-BIDEN MANIFESTO AND I
THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE
PERSON MENTIONED MOST IN THE
BIDEN CONVENTION, IS
DONALD TRUMP.
EVERY ADVERB OUT OF THEIR MOUTH.
IT TELLS YOU THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THEMSELVES HAS
NO CONFIDENCE IN THE COMPETENCE
IN THEIR NOMINEE JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN IS THE NOMINEE MEANS
THAT DONALD TRUMP CONTINUES TO
RUN AS THE OUTSIDER.
THE UNDERDOG, THE UNDERESTIMATED
OUTSIDER EVEN THOUGH HE’S THE
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT.
USUALLY THE CHALLENGE TO THE
INCUMBENT IS THE OUTSIDER, THAT
CANNOT POSSIBLY BE TRUE IF YOU
HAVE JOE BIDEN WHO IS DONE LESS
IN 47 YEARS IN WASHINGTON THEN
DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE 47 MONTHS
IN WASHINGTON.
>> Sean: YOU AND I LIVE AND
BREATHE AND EAT POLITICS AND
HAVE FOR DECADES.
IS THERE EVER BEEN A MAJOR
POLITICAL PARTY THIS RADICAL?
HE’S EMBRACED IT, HE’S OWNED IT
AND CLEARLY I GUESS BELIEVES IN
IT.
WE WILL SEE.
>> WE ALREADY KNOW WHAT THE
PUBLIC BANKS.
IF YOU LOOK AT POLLING ON ISSUES
WHICH IS ALWAYS MUCH MORE
TELLING THAN HORSE RACE BALLOT
QUESTIONS BECAUSE THOSE CHANGE
OVER TIME AS PEOPLE SOLIDIFY
THEIR BOATS AND LOOK AT THE
CANDIDATES AND MAKE THEIR
DECISIONS.
AMERICANS REJECT EVERYTHING THE
GREEN NEW DEAL STANDS FOR.
IT’S EXPENSIVE, INTRUSIVE,
INVASIVE, THE WORST OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BANNING COWS
AND GAS AND AIR TRAVEL AND THE
LIKE.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY VOTES THE
GREEN NEW DEAL GOT?
ZERO INCLUDING AMONG THE
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AT THE TIME, GOD ZERO
VOTES WHEN THEY HAD TO GO BACK
AND TELL THEIR CONSTITUENTS WE
SUPPORT THIS.
WE KNOW ABORTION AND THE NINTH
MONTH IS A NONSTARTER, WE KNOW
RAISING OUR TAXES, BUSINESS TAX
MOVING 35% DOWN TO 21% AND IF
YOU RAISE IT BACK UP AGAIN,
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WILL LOSE
THEIR JOBS.
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE DON’T WANT
THE BIG LIE OF THE LAST TEN
YEARS, TO CONTINUE UNDER
JOE BIDEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE HEALTH CARE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TRYING TO
MAKE HEALTH CARE MORE AFFORDABLE
AND MORE ACCESSIBLE.
LOOK AT ISSUE POLLING, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY RIGHT NOW IS
WAY OUT OF STEP WITH WHERE
AMERICANS ARE.
IT’S VERY ODD THAT JOE BIDEN WHO
BEAT DOWN ALL THOSE POLICIES AND
THE PEOPLE WHO STOOD FOR THEM IS
ROLLING BACK TO DEFENDANT
ROLLING BACK TO THE HARD LEFT
AND DOING THAT.
IF YOU USE ALL THE FOOTAGE OF
JOE BIDEN BRAGGING ABOUT HIS
VOTE ON NAFTA, DONALD TRUMP HAS
DONE AWAY WITH THAT.
MUCH BETTER FOR MEXICO, MUCH
BETTER FOR CANADA, MUCH BETTER
FOR THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
LOOK AT JOE BIDEN AND
BILL CLINTON BRAGGING ABOUT
THEIR BIG CRIME BILL IN 1994.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ENACTED
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM SUCH
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE OVERCHARGED
AN END OVER SENTENCED HAVE A
SECOND CHANCE AT LIFE AND WE
WILL BE HIGHLIGHTING THE NUMBER
OF THOSE PEOPLE NEXT WEEK AT OUR
PEOPLE’S CONVENTION.
YOU WILL SEE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN CONSEQUENTIALLY, MEASURABLY
IMPACTED IN THEIR LIVES BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IN THE
OVAL OFFICE AND HIS COMMANDER IN